by the way I should mention this and I
am concerned about Gary and I do love
Gary but I'm concerned about well you
tell me what you think of this Rob
alright gary has been going through
bottles of scotch and tequila during
quarantine like he's drinking
excessively oh really yeah I'm drinking
excessively you know so it depends on
what's going on like sometimes that
Friday cocktail hour
like I'll start at 5:30 which is way too
early but not for some people but for me
and then I go like this I'll have like
three tequila's you know on the rocks
it's on the rocks oh no that's too much
so then I'll just have a beer and I'll
have another beer and I'll go I can have
another tequila now then I realize that
was a lot are you wasted I don't know I
had a really bad weekend last week and I
just got like um I don't know like
almost like borderline depressed you
know and I mean it was really nice out I
just get like really bummed out about a
lot of stuff and I was almost like I
didn't want to go out and I just I just
all of what the future was like I never
get like that it just really was
upsetting to me see I'm built for
quarantine me sitting in my room by
myself is a typical four or five day jag
so I'm very happy by myself
Gary's a social animal like I've never
seen he loves to talk he he told me the
other day he went in front of the mirror
so he'd have someone to talk to I can't
explain I'm out of sorts I just don't
feel good and I'd like to lay down on
the couch for a while I was just feeling
yeah kitty yeah my jukebox you didn't
want to go visit your jukebox I did not
want to visit my jukebox
Gary pepper why don't you go upstairs to
your jukebox maybe you'll feel better I
don't wonder will there ever be another
day when I can visit my plantain bucket
in my office that the plantain sometimes
I pretend I pretend that Reilly my dog
is wilmarie how much chocolate are you
eating too because before Corona you it
was an immense amount of chocolate are
you going like apeshit with that
chocolate no it's it's the regular
amount of
that I'm eating the problem is I do have
to say that chocolate chips are hard to
find these days you know I love eating
the trunk chips they're not you know I
guess you just get chocolate chips I do
like to eat chocolate chips Wow by the
handful
this is terrible Gary puppet is hitting
the bottle right now and it's blue I'm
drinking six cases of scotch yes okay
six kids six cases of scotch and 500
pounds of Reese's
oh the liquor store man calls me Baba
Busey